a little bit of an outdoor question but
i think some of the interesting
qualities of
the human mind is the ideas of
intelligence and consciousness
so what do you make of consciousness so
do you think
death creates consciousness
like the fear of death the terror of
and consciousness
in turn magnifies
the terror of death i do um i i think
what is consciousness
to you oh don't ask me that so now
because
if i could answer that you know i'd be
chugging rum out of a coconut
with my nobel prize that um
you know it's literally you know stephen
pinker i do agree with
his claim and i think how the mind works
that it is the
key question for
the psychological sciences broadly
defined
in the 21st century what is conscious
yeah what is consciousness
and i don't think it's an epi
phenomenological afterthought
so a lot of people i think dan wagner at
harvard
a lot of folks consider it
just the ass end of a process
that by the time we are
aware of what it is it's just
basically an integrated rendering of
something that's already
happened you know evidently the there's
a half-second delay between when
something happens you know those studies
and our awareness
of it um um yeah and then that's where
like ideas of free will will step in
yeah you can explain away a lot of stuff
and i think those are all important
and interesting questions uh i'm of the
persuasion
i mean even not even but the
dawkins in the selfish gene um
is very thoughtful actually in a lot of
it's actually more in
notes than in the text of the book but
he's just like it's hard for me to
imagine
that consciousness
doesn't have some sort of
important and highly adaptive function
and what dawkins says is he thought
about it in terms of
just the that we could do mental
simulations
that one possibly
extraordinary product of consciousness
is
to rather than find out
often by adverse consequences through
trying something would be to run mental
simulations and so one possibility
is that consciousness is highly adaptive
another possibility is nicholas humphrey
a
british dude who wrote a book about i
think it's called regaining
consciousness
and he hypothesized i think this 1980s
maybe even earlier
that consciousness arose
as a way to better predict the behavior
of others in
social settings that by knowing how
i feel makes me better able
to know how you may be feeling this like
the rudiments of a theory of mind
and that it really may not have had
anything to do with
intelligence so much as social
intelligence
and so so in that sense consciousness
is a social construct like yes it's just
a useful thing for us
interacting with other humans yeah i i
don't know so but uh
there seems to be something um
about realizing your own mortality
that's somehow intricately connected to
the idea of consciousness well i think
so also
so this is where um and and nietzsche
um he said a solitary creature would not
need consciousness oh
what do you think well i don't know what
i think about that
but what i do and then he goes on to say
that consciousness is the most
calamitous stupidity by which we shall
someday perish
and wow i was like dude sorry uh
relax
[Laughter]
but so what if you say you were on an
island alone
and you saw a reflection of yourself in
in the water like
if you were alone your whole life yeah
great question
his view nietzsche's view would be that
your thoughts of yourself would never
come to mind
i don't know how i feel about that
though in a sense
this this sounds weird but in a sense
i feel like my mental conversation has
always been with death it's almost like
another
you know um another
notion like um you know there's these
visualizations of
of a death in the cloak like i always
felt like
i am a living thing and then there's an
other thing that is the end of me
and i'm having like a conversation with
that so in the sense that's
uh that's the way i construct my
the fact that i am a thing is because
there's
somebody else that tells me well you
won't be a thing
uh eventually wow this feels like a
conversation
um perhaps but that's uh that might be
kind of this
mental stimulation kind of idea that
you're you're kind of
it's not really it's a conversation with
yourself essentially sure
yeah but yeah i don't know how i feel
about
that but i i tend to be in agreement
with you when we're talking about
economics
more so that uh
that we're deeply social beings like
everything
the way it just feels like we're humans
i'm i'm with uh
harare with the science we're kind of
we seem to construct ideas on top of
each other and that's a fundamentally a
social
process absolutely i think that's a fine
book
it overlaps considerably
with our take on these matters and the
fact that
we get to these points drawing on
different sources i think makes me more
confident that
you